for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
okay so some of you may already be
somewhat aware of what's going on with
this but you can use the periodic table
to help you figure out what's going on
with electron configurations in fact we
can split the table up into blocks that
really help us figure out what's going
on the first thing I have to do is kind
of imagine helium let's do this in a
different color kinda have to imagine
helium being right over here in this
little space okay once we imagine that
it's actually pretty easy so let's
scroll down here we get what's called
the s-block p block d-block & F block so
the s-block is really just the first two
two columns right the D block is
basically the transition metals and the
p-block is the nonmetals over to the
right or at least most most of them on
all metals actually maybe not most of
them a lot of them are anyway the S lock
is two columns the D block is 10 columns
the p-block is six columns and the F
block is 14 columns what's going on
there let's think about this we got two
columns here six columns here ten here
and 14 here basically every time you
move over one element you add one
electron so here this would be like the
ns2 situation here we have the NP 6 here
we have the N d tens and here we have
the NF for teens so let's kind of put
all this together and see what actually
is going on ok basically you go through
and we we fill this accordingly in this
order so we have 1 s 1 and then 1 s 2
let me go to the right and then we do 2
s2 s1 to s2 and then to p 2 p 1 2 3 4 5
6 then we go to 3 s 3 s 13 s 2 and then
we go
23 p 1 through 6 then we go to 4s up to
2 and then we do 3d all the way up to 10
then we do 4p up to six then 5s up to 2
then 4d up to 10 then 5p up to six then
6s up to two and then there's just
little block here okay and that's
because this green F block is supposed
to actually insert right there so after
six f we go to 4f and once at once we
finish for F we go to 5d and then we go
to 6p after 6p we go to 7s and then we
drop down to 5 f after 5 f we have 6 D
and after 60 we've got 7p ok so let's
use this to do some configurations let's
start with p.m. which is promethium okay
so atomic number of 61 so that's down
here in the F block number 61 okay so
everything up until xenon is going to be
filled so let's start up at the top
though hydrogen helium that's 1 s2 so
we'll have 1 s 2 then we'll have 2s
lithium and beryllium 2 s 2 then over
here to p6 then 3s to starting with
sodium and magnesium and then 3 p-6 and
then 4s 2 and then 3 d 10 and then 4 p-6
and then 5s to then 4d 10 and then 5 p-6
then we have six s2 at cesium and barium
then we've got four F so we drop down
here and we have LA
EE P R and D and then M so that's 1 2 3
4 5 so that's going to be for f5 of
course we can shorten that to just XE
right xenon and right after that there's
six s2 and then for f5 so that's it for
that one let's try hf which is hafnium
so 72 so that's going to be everything
up until xenon as well so I'm going to
fill everything in up up to just before
six s the same way so 1s2 2s2 2p6 3s2
3p6 4s2 3d10 4 p-6 5s 24 d 10 5 p-6 6s
okay so cesium barium 24 f so the
hafnium the HF is after this that's part
of the the 5d portion so I have to drop
down to 4f go through all 14 of those
and then I start with this Lu over here
this this lu kind of actually has to be
you can imagine this it's actually
supposed to be right before a hafnium
right here okay so what that would be is
that would be 4f 14 and then 5d one at
seven at the 71 with the Lu and then 72
comes right after hafnium so that's 5d2
so the abbreviated version would be
Zenon and then 6s 24 f 14 and 5 d 24
lead notice that lead isn't the same row
as hafnium and it's after it right let
is over here 82 so it follows hafnium
hafnium is in the 5d portion right 5d
row so the five derail completes before
lead right so everything up until five D
is complete everything up through 5d is
complete so 1s2 2s2 2p6 3s2 3p6 4s2 3d10
4 p-6 5s 24 d 10 5 p-6 success 24 f 14
5d 10 and how many are in the p.o
TL and then PV so that's two so we've
got everything up through xenon and then
6s to 4f 1450 10 and 6 p-2 so that's the
electron configuration of lead so it's
an important note here it's important to
note here that using the Aufbau
principle guidelines you will get the
expected configuration which is what we
got here for all of these now doing that
won't always give you the actual
configuration especially when it comes
to DNF block elements I can get kind of
crazy but you just know that when it
oftentimes when you're asked questions
about electron configuration you really
asked what is the expected electron
configuration because you're using the
alfaab principles so I hope that video
is helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying